so if you watch a lot of Chess on
YouTube then it's very possible you've
come across the channel coffee chess
and earlier this year I flew to LA and I
played a lot of over-the-board Blitz
Games with the people at Coffee chess
now the first game that you're going to
see in this video was the very first
game I played against the owner of the
cafe where all the coffee chess people
meets and needless to say it was a
really crazy and just messy game and by
the end of the game things just got
super super chaotic so I hope you enjoy
the video I'll probably end up doing
some voice over commentary throughout
just to explain my thoughts and some of
the the strategies going through my mind
and also stay tuned for more videos from
my experience at Coffee chess they've
been posting a lot on their Channel
links will be below but you can expect a
lot more on this channel as well so hope
you enjoy and stay tuned
runs the place so oh very good yeah
all right so this is my first game in
coffee chess against Don the owner of
the cafe and as we're starting we
realize I should be having two minutes
to five minutes
so we fixed the clock and he begins with
the birds opening which is not the most
common and I respond with the froms
Gambit but a more rare variation of the
problems Gambit I sacrificed two pawns
and after it takes on C7 I'm threatening
to trap his Queen with Bishop takes C2
here so he correctly plays D3
and I develop my Bishop
so I have early leading development have
two Bishops and my queen out but after
his last move Pawnee four it's white
who's striking first in the center
and here I really wanted to sack a
bishop I was calculating Bishop takes
each two or Bishop G3 check but I
couldn't really make anything work
so after a bit of hesitation I do decide
to retreat
and he develops
now I want to say that going into this
game I had no idea what the level of my
opponent was
but as we played the opening phase I
realized that I'm playing a stronger
player than I initially imagined like
he's playing really really well so far
just taking the free material and
playing very solidly now my last name of
Bishop C5 is an attempt to prevent white
from casting kingside but he responds
with a very strong move Knight D5
establishing an outpost in the center
attacking my queen
and I was not feeling good here hardly
falling below a minute and here I
realized that this night has to go and I
decide to sacrifice my Rook for the
night
and go for this idea night before now
I'm attacking the pawn on D5 but I'm
also threatening to take the pawn on C2
setting up some very nasty Bishop F2
tactics to win some material back
but here he finds a move to defend
against all of my threats I think I I
realized it's coming this move Pawn to
C4
and after Knight to F6 I'm trying to
find some compensation but then he plays
Pawn A3 and my knight is just looking
very dumb on the B4 Square I didn't want
to retreat to A6
so I sacrificed the Knight Knight takes
G5 I do get a couple pawns for it but so
far this game I've sacrificed a couple
pawns a rook for Knights and now the the
night for a couple pawns so once we got
to this position I'm down a full rook
and not to mention I have 34 seconds
left to try and not lose the game
so things are already looking very Grim
for me
but I keep going still trying to play
quickly my goal is to try and exploit
his King in the center
and here he was very close to Queen side
castling which would have allowed me to
play Rook C8 to pin his Queen uh to the
King on the C file but he took it back
and plays a much better response and now
my Rook has a harder time entering the
game
so at this point I'm in survival mode
just trying to play quickly and keep the
game going
but I have 26 seconds he has still over
three minutes
now I'm clearly eyeing this E3 Square
here and he allows me to play 93 forking
his Queen and his Rook
but as we're gonna see I don't really
want to give up my Knights and I decide
not to take his Rook if I'm just trying
to get my Rook involved in the game
King D7 looks like a bad spot for my
king but now my plan is to play King
Yates
and at least enjoy the half open D file
for my Rook
he plays rookie one I play F5 my goal is
to reinforce my Knights I get the pawn
to F4 so now the Knight is actually a
very strong outpost on E3 Square
I'm still trying to play quickly Pawn to
G5
ideas of Pawn to G4 to harass the bishop
on F3
now of course at this point White's
completely just crushing me he ends up
sacking his Rook for the knights and
simplifies the position a bit white is
still up a full Bishop going after my
weak E3 Pawn
and he plays Queen D5 so my king is
still a Target in the center I'm down to
now under 16 seconds
but things are simplifying and my king
is somehow surviving
and he had just given back material so
if we count material now
it's actually completely equal we both
have a queen Rook bishop and four Pawns
but it's my king who is in a small
predicament had to walk up to the B6
Square
but I'm trying to get counter play
against his king queen G6
and queen F6
so when in doubt give a check
he's still playing very quickly and I
play the move A6 to give maybe some
potential hiding place for my king who's
breathing a lot of area on the B6 square
and he's still playing pretty quickly
and I have now just below 12 seconds
left but he's also getting low on time
so this is where things are about to get
really really insane
and I think now I'll just stop talking
maybe we'll play some dramatic music and
you'll see the insane finish to this
game
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]